offer that we fear is the best that can
be achieved at this stage through
negotiation
if the offer is accepted then it would
meet a key GMB demand of a huge pay
uplift for the lowest paid to keep them
well above the real living wage
progress has also been made on non-pay
demands such as addressing violence in
the workplace this offer is far from
perfect and of course our NHS workers
deserve more of gmb's a National
Committee is recommending that the offer
be accepted but the final decision
belongs to the members
strike action will be paused until the
outcome of the ballot so that the very
latest from Rachel Harrison then the key
lines takeaways that strike action will
be paused pending that ballot well let's
bring in our correspondent Matthew
Thompson who's at Union headquarters in
central London for us so that's uh the
update that we were looking for and
Rachel Harrison there positive that a
deal is almost completed
it certainly seems that way in fact a
deal looks as though it's been done at
least with the government and the
various unions involved a total of 14
unions involved in the negotiations but
with the caveat that Rachel Harrison was
just outlining there which is that this
is only to be recommended to the members
themselves and ultimately each Union's
members are the ones who have their
final sale we put to a member's ballot
but just in the last few seconds now we
have a statement a joint statement in
fact from the government themselves and
from the NHS staff Council which is the
umbrella group for those unions I was
mentioning a moment ago and they said
that the government the NHS staff
Council have completed negotiations and
reached a final offer this includes
additional pay for 2022-23 and a pay
settlement for 2023-24 so that's in line
with what we've been reporting through
the day we think a payoffer of something
in the region of five percent going
forward and then a one-off payment of
something like six percent but
presumably now that we have the deal
done we'll get the full details of
exactly what it entails but the
statement goes on both sides believe it
represents a fair and reasonable
settlement that acknowledges the
dedication of NHS staff while
acknowledging The Wider economic
pressures currently facing the UK those
unions with mandates for industrial
action so that's the Royal College of
nurses Unison the GMB the chartered
Society of physiotherapists unite and
the BDA will now consult their members
in consultations that will be held over
the coming weeks and importantly as you
rightly say strike action will be will
continue to be paused whilst these
ballots are ongoing so as I say it looks
as though we're there finally after well
a week and a half or so of fairly
intense negotiations a deal has been
agreed but with the important caveat
that that doesn't mean we're out of the
woods because this then goes back to the
members who ultimately have the final
say just two other things worth pointing
out is that yes this potentially brings
an end to the rolling strikes that have
played the NHS for a number months now
but importantly doctors are not included
in these negotiations so the junior
doctor strikes that we had this week for
example are not affected and actually
the British Medical Association the
union representing Junior doctors has
put out a statement a very short time
ago saying that they're now inviting
Stephen Barkley the health secretary to
sit down with them tomorrow to try and
hash out a deal of their own the second
thing worth pointing out is that the
moment and potentially this will become
clear as the afternoon goes on we're not
entirely sure where the money to fund
this is going to come from there was no
new money in the budget yesterday
certainly possible that the one-off
payment could be paid for via the
treasury reserves a reserve payment for
extra spending of around 14 billion
pounds that the treasury has this
financial year but in terms of where
they afford the five percent pay rise on
an ongoing basis from well that's not
entirely clear and if it comes from NHS
budgets well that might be a problem of
its very own making
Matthew thank you very much for that
update and staying across that story
well let's bring in our chief political
correspondent now John Craig who is in
Westminster for us there we know strike
action pause but what's the reaction
from the government John
well you've heard that statement from
Matthew there that there is uh uh where
the negotiations have been completed and
there's been a final offer well how many
times do we hear an industrial disputes
that it's the the final offer from the
employers we shall see but you have to
say listening to that GMB statement uh
that they seem uh minded to recommend to
their members to accept the offer now
that's only one Union
um on the based on the experience of the
last few weeks the unite Union which is
one of the three unions representing
ambulance Crews has been more militant
if you like or more determined to pursue
a better deal and uh just bit it's
entirely possible you could have one
Union uh backing the deal and another
light unite for example not backing it
uh clearly uh the GMB is minded to
accept the offer the at one point a few
weeks ago the government was attempting
at what was described by union leaders
as a divide and Rule trying to buy off
the Royal College of Nursing
traditionally obviously much more
moderate and less militant Union than
the others uh the nurses as opposed to
the ambulance Crews
um and as Matthew rightly says there's
still a pretty ugly dispute going on
involving the junior doctors whose
leaders claimed that a junior doctor
starts on less money than a barista in a
coffee shop so there's not much movement
there and of course there's no movement
yet on teachers either and any and
various other disputes and not obviously
government employers but the rail unions
and indeed Royal Mail so
um this is certainly the government will
see this as a breakthrough now that as
to where the money is coming from
um there is nothing in there in the
documents or any of the small print that
we saw yesterday from the budget
earmarked for this and the chancellor
didn't mentioned these strikes but of
course what ministers have been very
concerned about in recent weeks of
course is that as they do try and push
for growth and the economic growth and
the chancellor called it a budget for
growth what is one of the things that
really holds back growth of course is
industrial actions
lack of a loss of productivity and of
course in the terms of the National
Health Service
um one of the prime ministers five aims
is getting waiting lists down and health
bosses have been telling the government
uh till they're blue in the face the
employers how can we cut waiting lists
when our staff are on strike all the
time or many of them are on strike and
there has been a mood amongst NHS bosses
trusts employers organizations really
piling pressure on the government to
settle these disputes with first of all
the nurses and secondly the ambulance
Crews because it has been doing enormous
damage to the National or Health Service
and indeed really crippling the
government's attempts to get waiting
lists down so been massive pressure on
the chancellor and indeed Mr Barclay the
health secretary they clearly have made
an improved offer but uh whilst the GMB
seemed to be saying to their members we
think it's a good deal at this stage
um the we don't haven't heard that from
the other unions yet as far as I know
let me just double check
um here I have uh yeah now that's I
think this is a from this is the Royal
College of Nursing I think yeah um so um
yeah in addition to a commitment from
the Royal College of Nursing the
government's agreed to new pay for all
nursing stuff this looks like an offer
to nurses right
so the um the receipt appears to be an
offer to nurses as well
um a one-off payment for the current
Financial year between 1655 and 3 000
nearly 3 800
um and five percent for a next year so
that seems to be an improved offer to
nurses as well here so we are looking at
uh offers to two key groups of workers
in the National Health Service the
ambulance Crews and the nurses so um we
will see what the response is obviously
they are the GMB who've talked to uh in
terms of perhaps recommending to their
members to accept this uh of course it
has to go to a ballot that's probably
going to take a couple of weeks but
because the unions are pausing further
industrial action the government will be
hopeful that this is an end to these
very damaging disputes
um but um of course there are several
groups of workers and several trade
unions here so we shouldn't assume
assume that these strikes are over yet
and there is a deal yet these offers
have to be put to the members and whilst
they are a big Improvement really on at
one point the government was talking
about three and a half percent
um that was going back towards the back
end of last year it's a big Improvement
but it's still nowhere near what the
unions have been asking for for example
the Royal College of Nursing started off
by asking for 19 then Pat Cullen a few
months ago said okay we might consider
half of that say 10 well this these
offers are still short of that so it is
entirely possible they may be rejected
but of course if the unions do recommend
it do recommend accepting them well that
will be a boost for the government and
could bring about the end of the these
that very damaging disputes so we await
uh some words perhaps from Mr Barclay
the health secretary who has been
holding talks over the last few days we
await also words from other trade unions
involved here but just to recap the GMB
uh one of the major unions representing
ambulance workers ambulance Crews does
seem to be recommending that it is the
best offer they can expect to get yes
John we do wait to hear from Stephen
Barkley but I wonder if you give me your
assessment uh thus far as to how
damaging uh this whole episode has been
for the government
well massively as I've mentioned
um one of Rishi sunak's five priorities
is to get waiting lists down and we know
that the NHS employers have been
pleading with the government to come up
with more money saying how can we get
waiting lists down when the staff are on
strike whether it's the nurses or
whether it's the ambulance Cruise we've
seen some shocking figures of the time
people are waiting for ambulances we've
heard shocking stories uh every week in
prime minister's questions MPS on the
opposition benches get up and raise
stories of people waiting hours having
treatment canceled and so on and clearly
the Prime Minister has probably
presumably banged some heads together we
know that the prime minister is on a bit
of a he would see it as being on a bit
of a role at the moment trying to solve
a lot of very difficult problems we
started off with the the Northern
Ireland protocol then of course we had
we had the legislation on the small
boats then we had the budget yesterday
and uh of course whilst there was
nothing yesterday from the chancellor it
does seem that here we are 24 hours or
so after the budget John the price the
Prime Minister and the governments are
trying to solve this problem John I'm
just going to cut in there because we
can bring Steve Barkley very latest uh
comments on that deal that we believe
has been reached
well the government's made a formal
offer to the NHS staff Council that I've
just come out of a meeting with them I'm
very pleased that they've agreed to
recommend to their members it will be
for a five percent pay rise next year
2023 24 but also an additional lump sum
in terms of this year which is
additional to the award through the pay
review body which was on average 4.75
and then what that will mean for example
for a newly qualified nurse is over 1
800 this year on top of that prb award
and a pay rise of over 1 300 pounds next
year and obviously that increases for
more senior nurses in higher grades now
of course some of that money for this
year is a one-off payment which means it
doesn't go long term into the salaries
of those people you've said frequently
that you wouldn't look at this year's
pay why didn't you do this earlier well
we have listened to the concerns of the
train units we've had meaningful
discussions with them we're both sides
of engaged constructively obviously the
starting position from the number of the
unions was much higher and so both sides
have worked together to reach a
settlement which is both affordable to
The Wider taxpayer and balances the very
real pressures we recognize that NHS
workers have been on so this balance was
required on both sides that is what the
talks explored and that's why I very
much welcome that we've reached a
settlement with the NHS staff Council
that balances our commitment in
government to get inflation down to look
at the cost and what was affordable to
The Wider economy to taxpayers but that
also recognize the very real pressures
that NHS staff faced through the
pandemic and particularly through the
recent winter so an important question
how much is it going to cost and how
will it be funded uh well we've been
clear that it will not come at the
expense of uh impact on patients
obviously how these things are funded or
a matter for the chancellor and we
discuss that within government uh but
we've been offered any new money he
didn't in the budget very clear in terms
of the conditions of the discussions we
had with the trade unions that this will
not come from patient-facing aspects of
course we will look at areas of
understand as an administrative saving
and discuss these things with the
treasury in the usual way but the
commitment is one that the trade unions
have recognized is Meaningful it
reflects very constructive engagement
with them it means there will be a lump
sum additional four NHS staff this year
recognizing the pressures and a five
percent settlement for next year
the funding isn't important though there
are Hospital trusts who are very
concerned that even if some of this has
to come out of existing budgets it's
going to mean more pain for patients
well we're being clear that as part of
the discussions we had this would not
come from areas of the budget that
impact on patients so those was part of
the terms of the discussions that we had
that was the nature of the negotiation
now that was part of the Monday I
received from the Prime Minister and
from the chancellor there are many
people though who will look at this and
say this dispute has been going on for
months there was talk of a one-off
payment several weeks ago months ago in
fact were you blocked from doing that
and pursuing that by the treasury well
we take decisions across government
these things are entered into
collectively of course part of my job as
the Health and Social care secretary is
to advocate for the NHS within
government in exactly the same way that
the education secretary will do so for
teachers or the transport secretary for
train drivers my job is to make the case
for the NHS within government of course
that is something that I have been doing
over recent months but we make these
decisions collectively I'm very pleased
we've reached a settlement which the NHS
staff Council feel able to recommend to
their members it balances our commitment
to get inflation down to guard the
interests of the taxpayer but does so in
a balanced way that also reflects the
the very real pressures that the NHS has
been under over recent years you've been
forced to the negotiating table haven't
you by the strike action and for those
people who've had operations and
treatment canceled postponed potentially
for months or years they're going to say
you should have done something sooner
well there's been significant movement
in terms of what the trade unions were
originally asking for for example one of
the trade unions originally was
suggesting a 19 settlement so there's
been movement on all sides we moved some
time ago though didn't they well not to
the position that we are on today so
there's been further constructive
engagement we've had intensive talks
over many days there's been movement on
both sides and that reflects the
balanced nature of the settlement we've
reached looking after the interests of
taxpayers getting inflation down but
recognizing the real pressures that the
NHS has faced and just finally I know
you'll be pleased of course that you
seem to have reached an agreement here
but Junior doctors this doesn't include
Junior doctors does it no my door is
open I look forward to having
discussions with them clearly we entered
the talks with the agenda for change
trade unions on the basis of them
suspending their strikes respecting the
engagement principles I welcome the the
leadership that the trade unions have
shown in those discussions we've built a
discussions that have respected the
confidentiality uh throughout both sides
have been willing to work in a very
constructive way and I hope the junior
adopters will take note of that and
reflect that in their approach over the
coming weeks and your message to them is
they need to suspend strike action is
that right yes that's the principles
which the other trade unions accepted
the RCN unite Unison the GMB all
respected that we've offered the same
terms to the junior doctors that were
accepted by those other trade unions and
that's what I hope the junior doctors
will respond to but I a request from
them for a pay rise of 35 is not
affordable that's why we need to see
from them the same sort of leadership
that we've seen from the trade unions in
the agenda for change contract
it's from Stephen Barkley the health
secretary there on the agreement with
the unions over a pay deal Paving the
way or an end to the industrial action
want to bring in our correspondent
Matthew Thompson who's uh with the GMB
in central London for us so we have the
health secretary there Matthew
um update us on what the Union's saying
well the deal is now done at least as
far as it can be it's very much now in
uh ball the ball being passed now to the
the union memberships if you like
because ultimately they're the ones who
will have the say on this the union
bosses can only recommend the deal and
ultimately it has to be accepted by the
membership but for the time being there
is an agreement finally after a week or
so of fairly intense negotiations by all
accounts between the government and the
unions and who better to update us on
those negotiations than Sarah Gorton the
head of Health at Unison and the chair
of the NHS unions
um you've been locked behind closed
doors with the health secretary for some
considerable time now are you pleased
with the result
well the offer that is on the table
today was hard won by health workers so
you know you've been covering the
strikes since December so it's taken
several months of disruption to the
Public's services in the NHS members
have lost lost money and health workers
have been Resolute and that's resulted
in an offer coming forward whether it is
good enough will as you said you know
we'll rest with the health workers
themselves but the elected committees in
unison in GMB in the BDA the CSP the
Royal College of Nursing have voted
today to recommend the deal as the best
that can be achieved through negotiation
so that's an interesting caveat because
what I was going to ask you is is this
in your view a good deal or just the
best deal that was achievable under the
circumstances I think well I mean you
always take these things in context
don't you I mean it would have been
better if we'd had this level of
investment put in the Health Service
this time last year because then we
wouldn't have faced a situation where so
many people left to go and work for
better paid and less stressful jobs
elsewhere that said you know we've got
an increase of six percent of the pay
bill which is not an insignificant
amount of money and hopefully might go
some way to addressing people's cost of
living pressures and you know help
employers retain staff throughout what's
going to be a really busy summer you
rightly say this obviously has to go to
the memberships who will ultimately
decide but with the memberships looking
at this you know a 5.2 percent pay rise
would they rightly be disappointed given
that at least one Union the Royal
College of nurses started off wanting 19
quite a lot lower well the joint um The
Joint trade unions aimed to get close to
inflation we wanted an inflation busting
pay increase what we've got if you you
know you're adding Consolidated
increases from last year with a lump sum
which she's very very crude maths but
you know broadly the investment is over
10 on the pay bill
um which if if it happened at times when
people were facing their stiff bills
then you know that would have that would
have been uh considerably more helpful
so it is a you know it is a decent sum
of money I have done my level best to
give members a credible choice so health
workers can now decide between taking
further strike action and picking up an
offer I know that you know me and other
trade unions work together to uh to
engage with the government and press for
as much money as we could you know as
much additional investment the lump sum
payments that health staff would receive
if they were to pick this offer up range
from a minimum of sixteen hundred pounds
just over 1600 at the bottom of the pay
scale most people at the top of band
five so band five is where most of the
registered occupations so occupational
therapists nurses physiotherapists
dietitians where they come in and it
will be two thousand pounds for those
people so a not inconsiderable sum of
money and because we've been able to
negotiate now for the pay rise for the
following pay year people would have the
security of knowing that was in their
pay packets early and applicable from
the first of April rather than waiting
and crossing their fingers to see what
comes out of the pay review body in the
summer given that there is not an offer
on the table an improved offer as and
and for all those reasons you outline
and given the disruption that this has
by your Union's own admission calls to
the Health Service is there no more of a
more pressure more of a moral obligation
on staff to accept this and and go back
to work well I'd say the moral
obligation was all on the Secretary of
State you know all we said right from
the start was that we would rather have
had the opportunity to talk
rather than take industrial action you
know all of the all of the the
paramedics the nurses the healthcare
assistants the cleaners the whole team
of the NHS who you've spoken to during
the course of this dispute all of them
will have told you that they would
rather have their unions in rooms
negotiating to get them an improved
offer than taking action we consistently
ask for talks the whole way through this
dispute this has been hard one members
deserve to have a choice the public
deserves to have a Health Service that
has better investment so trade unions
today are pleased that we have the
opportunity to give them that choice
Sarah Gordon Head of Health at Unison
thank you very much indeed so there we
have it the view from the unions but it
is ultimately as I said over to the
memberships and also some outstanding
questions about where this money
actually comes from there was no extra
money in the budget yesterday for this
the health secretary you heard him in a
clip short time ago suggesting that it
wasn't going to come from NHS pay pots
for example but that wasn't necessarily
a paper plus energized budget but but
that's not a that's not a complete
ruling out the possibility that it comes
from somewhere else in the NHS and the
issue with that is if there's no new
money from the central government in the
budget well then it's got to come from
somewhere within the health uh spending
envelope so that potentially creates
further problems at somewhere down the
line for someone else to resolve that is
the future question to ask for the
moment though thank you Matthew well if
you are just joining us a potential
major breakthrough has been announced
that could end many of the strikes
heaping pressure on the NHS unions
representing staff including nurses
ambulance drivers and physios but not
Junior doctors have reached a payoffer
with the government and have paused
their industrial action while they put
it to members
all NHS staff would receive a five
percent pay rise for the next financial
year starting from April
health workers would also receive two
one-off bonuses for this year
one of those would be a covid recovery
bonus which will range from 1.5 for the
highest paid and 6.2 percent for the
lowest
the offer covers all NHS staff including
nurses paramedics 999 call handlers but
it doesn't include doctors as I said
well let's bring in our chief political
correspondent John Craig who's in
Westminster uh a deal seemingly struck
Jon but not quite over the line just yet
well of course the uh the unions may be
wrecked at least two of the unions that
we've heard from are recommending uh
that it's a good deal or the best they
can get let me bring you some words from
the Prime Minister
um arishi sunak has said I'm really
pleased that after several weeks of
constructive talks the government and
the agenda for change unions have come
to an agreement that will provide a fair
deal for NHS staff and put disruptive
strike action behind us Mr sunac says
it's right that we reward our
hard-working NHS staff who shared
bravery and dedication throughout the
pandemic and continue to make phenomenal
progress to tackle waiting lists
importantly this deal is also affordable
for the taxpayer and continues to
deliver on my promise to halve inflation
and we've taken a reasonable approach
throughout throughout and this offer is
good for NHS staff it's good for the
taxpayer most importantly it's good news
for patients whose care air will no
longer be disrupted by strike action
well Mr sunac there is saying it's
affordable for the taxpayer
um and uh of course he talks about his
Target one of his five priorities is
getting inflation down well obviously
he's obviously had one eye on that but
also getting waiting lists down uh the
that is one of his also one of his
priorities and uh it's uh one of the
things that NHS bosses have been uh
really knocking on the government's door
and saying please come up with some
money to solve these disputes because
how can we get waiting lists down uh
when our staff are on strike so many
days over the past few months now
um speaking a short time ago Steve
Barkley the health secretary
um when he was asked where the money's
going to come from he said well it's not
going to come out of the budget for a
treatment and patience and so he also
significantly said he had been making
the case within government for this cash
so clearly there's been a lot of
pressure on both the Prime Minister and
the chancellor Jeremy hunts to come up
with this cash
this extra cash this was uh what Mr
Barkley was saying just a very short
time ago about what appears to be a very
significant breakthrough
well the government's made a formal
offer to the NHS staff Council that I've
just come out of a meeting with them I'm
very pleased that they've agreed to
recommend to their members it will be
for a five percent pay rise next year
2023-24 but also an additional lump sum
in terms of this year which is
additional to the award through the pay
review body which was on average 4.75
percent and then what that will mean for
example for a newly qualified nurse is
over 1 800 this year on top of that prb
award and a pay rise of over 1 300
pounds next year and obviously that
increases for more senior nurses in
higher grades now of course some of that
money for this year is a one-off payment
which means it doesn't go long term into
the salaries of those people you've said
frequently that you wouldn't look at
this year's pay why didn't you do this
earlier well we have listened to the
concerns of the train units we've had
meaningful discussions with them we're
both sides of engaged constructively
obviously the starting position from the
number of the unions was much higher and
so both sides have worked together to
reach a settlement which is both
affordable to The Wider taxpayer and
balances the very real pressures we
recognize that NHS workers have been on
so this balance was required on both
sides that is what the talks explored
and that's why I very much welcome that
we've reached a settlement with the NHS
staff Council that balances our
commitment in government to get
inflation down to look at the cost and
what was affordable to The Wider economy
to taxpayers but that also recognize the
very real pressures that NHS staff faced
through the pandemic and particularly
through the recent winter
so Mr Barclay was then asked how how
much is it going to cost and how will it
be funded uh his answer was uh we've
been clear it will not come at the
expense of impact on patients how these
things are funded are a matter for the
chancellor and we discussed that within
government so
um that was the response to that
question from Mr Barclay I can now bring
you a response from Steve Bryan he's the
conservative MP who chairs the Health
and Social care Select Committee in the
House of Commons and Mr Brian says this
the news of a breakthrough pay offer to
NHS workers is a good outcome for
patients and staff I hope it will
provide a solid basis for pay
settlements going forward for anyone
who's been affected by canceled
appointments and longer Waits this has
been a difficult time tackling the
backlog is a priority for the NHS that
will take all the efforts and hard work
of the staff upon which our Services
depends so he obviously
is hoping the unions will back this Mr
Brian is a longtime Ally of uh Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor going back to when
he was one of Mr Hunt's Junior ministers
when Mr Hunt was was Health secretary so
um it's uh it's uh the uh clearly they
found the money from somewhere the
chancellors found the money slightly old
that he didn't say yesterday uh when we
were all listening and MPS were all
listening to the budget statement and I
can announce that I've found some money
for the NHS staff but obviously you want
that the the negotiations were clearly
at a delicate stage then and that's why
we've had to wait 24 hours but
um the uh I should just say actually
we've heard um quite um approving
reaction from the GMB and the uh and the
Unison trade unions I should just say we
we await news from unite because their
General Secretary Sharon Graham has
taken I might say a more hardliner
approach and if one Union is not going
to accept this it would probably be
unite we also haven't heard yet from Pat
Cullen the General Secretary of the
Royal College of Nursing now as as we
know he the RCN was originally
um was originally demanding as Mr
Barkley I think said just a moment ago
uh 19 at one point then Pat Cullen said
well actually we'd settle for half of
that what's being offered here is
nothing like half of that and so it's
always the possibility that the unions
will reject these uh these offers of the
one-off payments and the and the pay
rise
it's a very legitimate question and no
doubt the government's political
opponents will say this could have been
settled ages ago because the whole idea
of a one-off payment was floated a
couple of months ago now in the early
part of this year January from memory
and at that point it did appear that the
treasury was blocking that so clearly
there's been a pretty big change of
hearts at the very top of government
both in the treasury and in number 10
and clearly the government has taken the
the view
um that that um this really how they
really have got to bring these disputes
to an end so um the uh the government
you can say perhaps the government has
blinked first here because they've
improved their offer it is possible the
biggest breakthrough we've had uh in
this whole dispute uh but we await the
reaction from a couple of the other
major trade unions and uh we but clearly
the government uh both the Prime
Minister the health secretary and indeed
senior MPS like the chairman of the
health select committee they are very
much hoping that the unions will back
this offer and bring to an end these
ruinous strikes which have been really
damaging for the NHS both in terms of
waiting lists and as we've heard uh from
canceled operations and real misery for
many many patients John thank you John
Craig there with the line from the
government let's see what the unions
have to say we'll bring our
correspondent Matthew Thompson who's in
central London for us Matthew
well John mentioned there a number of
unions the RCN and the GMB and we hadn't
heard in fact from from Pat Cullen who's
the head of the Royal College of nurses
who'd been one of the the harder line
negotiators we have not heard from back
Helen almost as he was speaking she says
that she now feels Vindicated for the
pressure uh that the Royal College of
nurses and others were able to put the
government out there she under she
admits that it's not a Panacea to the
problems but it's a significant deal and
she's urging members to accept it
although they understand why members may
not want to and you've got to think
perhaps for particularly Royal College
of nurses members who were at one stage
being told that their Union was
advocating for a 19 pay rise or they
might feel a little bit shortchanged but
let's see what happens in the coming
weeks we also have a statement from the
GMB Union Rachel Harrison the national
secretary said in a rather lengthy
statement but I hope you'll bear with me
thanks to the strength and hard work of
gmb's NHS members the government has
gone from refusing to talk about pay
this year to putting an extra two and a
half billion pounds on the table GMB
members she said should rightly be proud
of themselves it's been a tough road
but they face down the Department of
Health and won an offer that we feel is
the best that can be achieved at this
stage through negotiation if the offer
is accepted then it would meet a key GMB
demand of a huge pay uplift for the
lowest pay to keep them well above the
real living wage progress she continued
has also been made on non-pay demands
such as addressing violence in the
workplace this offer is far from perfect
and of course our NHS workers deserve
more gmb's National Committee is
recommending that the offer be accepted
but the final decision belongs to our
members and then importantly they finish
by saying strike action will be paused
until the outcome of the ballot nothing
what's very interesting about the tone
generally from the unions we heard from
Sarah Gordon from Unison who I
interviewed a moment ago certainly from
the GMB from the Royal College of nurses
as well is it's almost a cautious
recommendation it's almost like they're
accepting that they didn't quite get
what they want they're not coming out
saying this is the best deal you know
we're so delighted with this deal even
there in that GMB statement they said
well we actually think health workers
deserve more but what the settled view
appears to be both on the record and
speaking to Union sources off the Record
is that they've come to uh the
realization if you like that this was
the best deal that they were going to
get
at least without doing another six
months of strike action with all the
moral quandaries that that would entail
so it's a cautious recommendation from
the unions but fundamentally it's over
to the members to decide
okay Matthew thank you very much for the
moment just to bring some breaking news
on this story and update we're hearing
that unite are rejecting the offer
that's the the very latest unite Union
rejecting that offer from the government
of the five percenter pay rise
additional lump sum and the one-off
payment um John Craig is in Westminster
back so soon John and we were just
talking about whether all the Unions
would sign into this and uh unite say no
Jillian I can bring you a statement from
unite this is from Sharon Graham the
general secretary she says it's clear
that the government has been forced into
negotiations
um it's clear that the government has
been forced into negotiations and the
subsequent move because of strike action
and the support of the public for the
NHS she says the offer from government
is not one that unites can recommend to
our members but ultimately it's
important that our members make the
final decision unite will support
members in whichever decision they now
make as unite members are being
consulted a strike action will be paused
so I think I was speculating a few
moments ago that you if one Union if it
was if one of the unions was going to
reject this it probably would be unite
so that is a statement from Sharon
Graham she says that they can't
recommend it but it's a the final
decision is for the members they'll
support their members whatever decision
but they are also pausing their strike
action so unite is saying no but it's up
to their members to decide okay John
thank you very much for that update well
let's get some reaction now to the
payoffer with one of the nurses that has
been striking Antonia berylson Antonio
thanks very much for speaking to us just
to say up front obviously you're an RCN
member what is your first inclination to
vote for this increased payoff or not
my first inclination is um incredible
disappointment really
um it's a desired advisory offer
um and it's not keeping up with the cost
of inflation and the rank and farm
membership are pretty perturbed by it to
be honest
we've just broken the news that unite
are not going to advise their members to
vote for this you are in agreement with
that thought
I am indeed and I mean we all voted for
industrial acting with very heavy heart
because none of us nurses wanted to but
we're struggling with the cost of living
bills are going up and our pay is just
not keeping up but don't forget it's
been over 12 years of below inflation
pay Rises so essentially we're asking to
come to terms with the fact that we have
been having a pay loss for many many
years
um we're seeing hemorrhaging
experiencing experienced staff believing
um and we're not recruiting the nurses
and this pay offer is simply not good
enough Pat Cullen has said that she
feels Vindicated for putting pressure on
government to get to this stage and
she's urging members to accept the offer
originally started at 19 that was the
initial call from the RCN Whittle down
to five percent will you then disregard
Pat Cullen's call to accept what has now
been offered
Julian you know it's a union led by
members and our us as members we're
really really struggling you know just
today and now spoke to me how he can't
afford to fill his prescription for his
own health because of the the wages he's
getting and he's a band eight which is a
high band it's simply not good enough
you know during covert we lost our
colleagues you know I sat by the
bedsides of people in inadequate PPE
this is all about political choices and
it's simply simply not good enough
because you know as a nurse I'm
absolutely passionate and I wanted this
the NHS to continue I want there to be
staff I want nursing to be a valued
profession it's a university we're a
university educated professionals and
yet we're having to think whether or not
we will put the heating on you know
question what you know I'm a single
parent struggling to pay my bills and
this will not it's it's a start but it's
simply the pay offer is not good enough
Antonio I can see that uh you're very
passionate about this and getting a
little emotional but you
will say that this is no way near what
you should have what what figure
are you thinking of
foreign
we're looking at over 12 years of below
inflation pay rise we need to have a pay
a pay offer that meets inflation for the
very least not to mention the fact that
they're offering a one-off deal which
will affect many nurses are on universal
credits this one-off payment will affect
them we need to ensure that we are
having an adequate pay deal an adequate
pay deal that is above inflation
um and just don't forget that due to
higher than expected um tax on receipts
the government announced not so long ago
they've got 30 billion the money is
there and it is all about political
choices you know we need to ensure the
NHS continues because the NHS is one of
our greatest institutions and we need a
healthy working population that ensures
that we need to cut waiting lists we
need to ensure that people are having
their appointments but the only way to
do it is simply to get the staff in
unless we have the pay that reflects the
role we do unless we have the pay that
reflects the fact that when covered
happened nobody could doubt our
integrity we were there on the front
line you know we we're breaking bad news
we're doing the roles that Junior
doctors did many years ago and our Pace
simply does not reflect that
responsibility and the hours aren't paid
not to mention you know we need to have
they make this attractive attractive
profession to ensure that we can make
meet the demands of an increasing aging
population that the governments suggest
that they are allowing some of the the
fears that that you've raised that it's
a five percent pay rise for the next
financial year that also uh be two
one-off bonuses for this year and um one
of those would be a covid recovery bonus
you were mentioning the the situation
during the the pandemic and that will
range from 1.5 for the highest paid and
6.2 percent for the lowest and this
covers all NHS staff including nurses
and paramedics and 999 call handlers
that still does not meet what you think
you require
no it's it's inadequate and it's too
late you know covered we've had years
and years of below inflation pay rise
it's not enough and the fact that we had
to wait for so long to even start to
have a payoffer it's not good enough and
the members are definitely you know
perturbed by the level of the offer we
deserve more for sure Antonio Barrison
thank you very much for speaking to us
this afternoon a nurse who has been
involved in strike action as part of the
dispute
let's take a look at the rest of the
day's news now for you and ministers
have banned the chinese-owned social
media app Tick Tock from all UK
government phones tech talk has been
under increasing scrutiny over its
security and data privacy with concerns
it could be used to promote pro-beijing
views and gather user data Tick Tock
denies the claims and says it's
disappointed by the UK's decision
as many colleagues will know social
media apps collect and store huge
amounts of user data including contacts
user content and geolocation data
on